in five four three two one welcome
everybody to another episode of the
genius brain podcast I got a very
special guest today and like I said
genius brain is about the celebrities in
my personal life and I call this lady my
African sunshine let me warm you up her
first name literally is what you and
yourself at the prayer with amen
always think that that's fake they're
like so like really like am A and E and
yeah yeah I know your mom your mom is
the most spiritual woman ever been in my
life my mom loves you Dave really you
and Khalif and Z and though she was like
do wonder how's that do whites and black
sheds is he okay yeah he's just really
quiet my you know wise because he did
get his feet washed but he later told me
that he wished that he did yeah of
course he wished that he did it was me
all weird about that [ __ ] like his feets
that special with the thug you got some
regular ass because this is the same
person who has OCD that's right the same
person that will you go out to eat and
he only eats like a little bit of his
food and it says that he's form like
ninja we just got there's like a solid
110 pounds he's my thigh that's what it
is
he legit I think what he weighs right
now is what I weighed in the 5th grade
like same [ __ ] level was extra tiny what
you been up to man life man literally
life transitioning from one thing to
another but yeah you know I'm an
editorial associate right now at a
marketing firm and then on the weekends
I'm hosting a Christian radio show but
it's not your typical Christian radio
show it's like we mean you talk about
stuff that most people don't want to
talk about in the church so oh [ __ ] like
what what like this past weekend we
talked about like you know
well we talked about sex two weekends
ago and masturbation oh [ __ ] all that
kind of doesn't let you know every I've
never met a single question that doesn't
masturbate yeah and but the thing is is
nobody talks about it that's the problem
like you know people yeah you know what
that's true maybe it's just because like
well you know because I grew up in a
church but then I just think I think I
was the Antichrist in the church talk
about everything you probably a comedic
relief in church probably probably like
shut up Dave but not know Antichrist so
you guys really talk about all that snow
yeah we did we talked about sex we
talked about like why do we look at sex
as a negative thing you know or why do
we shame some people for having sex but
we just wanted we want people to get to
the mindset that if you're having sex do
it with the right people because there's
so many emotional and spiritual ties
that come with it you got to be mindful
who you share your body with yeah and so
for me I have everybody on the panel has
had sex except for me because I'm
keeping myself for marriage
man that you are let me tell you
something you are a steel Forge
oh no it's hard because I almost lost my
virginity twice I'll see I'll tell you
that but but I stopped myself every time
because I knew that me I'm an empath
that's one thing I'm very emotional I
get attached easily in a romantic sense
so if I shared myself with this man who
was also cheating on me behind my back
son of a [ __ ] I would have been like
this would have been like you know
waiting to exhale when you find that
[ __ ] out through Facebook people suck at
cheating you have you you know that [ __ ]
then suck at cheating like you muted
cheap you got to do the steps you had to
delete your facebook you'll eat
everything yeah but the thing is is like
one of my friends already hinted like oh
you need to be let me not say his name
how much you want I bet you he's like
Skinner's [ __ ] me
no always dude straight I don't know why
but I'm like no he was a little bit
lighted it mean oh really
yeah the African yep he's ebo what yeah
so this [ __ ] you listen I so
what was true about the whole situation
was I basically printed out the
conversation I couldn't I message the
girls like [ __ ] in this I'm both like
cuz you crossed me the thing is people
know me as being nice but when you get
on my other side it's a whole nother
problem
Oh a hundred percent 100 percent you
said there wasn't a video you would have
seen that lip curl of anger right there
my I get real ghetto I get real ratchet
it's like sophisticated ratchet African
like it's like so fat yeah I don't know
like it's all together I messaged her
and so I printed out all our
conversations she told me everything in
detail I put in like a little folder put
it in a gift bag put tissue went to his
house you [ __ ] funny so like we were
supposed to go work out and so I was
like babe let's go let me meet you like
maybe 10 minutes earlier at your house
and he was like okay that's cool come to
his house he comes out and he's like so
what we gonna do today but I said I
actually have a gift for you and I
passed it to him and he was like what is
this and I was like open it I'm sorry
okay takes the tissue out takes the
envelope out he's like what the it was
thick cuz I talked to her over weeks
cuz I wanted to know everything he opens
and he starts reading it and I said I
get in the car because I'm standing with
the door open yeah I get in the car and
so I shut the door I rolled out my glass
I'm like looking at him read it and his
eyes just go and I was like exactly lose
my number you never knew me you know and
I don't curse I was like f you and sped
off he called me 11 times after that the
first three but what's he gonna say when
those 11 times what's there to say
unless it's like she lying or you know
this is July or this is this an
or Baba blast so the first three
voicemails were basically like him
saying like I'm sorry that's not what
you think that it then the last message
was fu we never said that this this
addition of course yeah so then he went
back and told the girl like hey I'm
crazy that I'm some crazy girl whatever
whatever I said I'm crazy these are the
pictures of me and him
I've been knowing him since I was in
high school oh [ __ ] and you guys go way
back to 6 - okay whoa no mom sorry a
buck 8000 bucket well [ __ ] you then make
sure I kiss I see him because he knows
me Houston next week I wanna see the
easy muscular I don't know so I deleted
him from Facebook I don't follow him on
Instagram see I'm very careful about how
I talk [ __ ] about people just because my
cloud in Houston may be way bigger than
his yeah [ __ ] you then I went to HBCU
for undergrad I had all kinds of friends
if you know I mean whether they was
Crips Bloods big you know what with the
wrong person
don't mess just pick them all together
up you all behind them I'll be talking
mad [ __ ] from the back I cut my finger
in the back of my head to the [ __ ]
front like that but it was crazy because
during that time after that happened for
a long time I questioned everything when
it came to romantic relationships
of course it's like you know somebody
who was showing interest to me was like
doing all this good stuff but and deep
down inside I kind of felt like man
something ain't right but I'm just gonna
look over when you're emotionally
attached it's hard to kind of look at
those type of things but you tend to
ignore the the natural instincts that
you have cuz your gut feeling for me I
feel like it's always right there's
there's something that you have through
all these like cumulative experiences
that says something's not right with
this person but with you when you're
like emotionally attached that you
choose to just push it down and then
just like you know what maybe maybe I'm
wrong this time
ya down and you move on but look what
happened exactly and so for me now ever
since that whole ordeal I've been very
I just have standards now just cautious
yeah very cautious you've got your heart
but uh I'm 30 now like that's our 30th
September and I'm red you been ready
since you were 12 over baked cake well
let me ask you this then like you know
when you when you're super passionate
about somebody within a relationship and
I always wanted this to so first of all
I wanted to save my virginity to I
lasted till I was 17 so that was
actually pretty good for people my age
at the time yeah 18 7 18 18 18 18
give me another year so and even then it
was hard so when I was when I was
working at a church and I remember these
kids they would ask cuz you know I was I
was like a youth minister for a little
bit and these kids would ask you what if
I just have sex ones no son let me taste
them you have just eat pie ones you ever
just have a slice of pie in every pie
ever again what kind of power any pie
that you like mmm what's your favorite
piece of pie I used to like pecan pie
but they put so much high fructose corn
syrup are you all mad healthy now huh
yeah
I'm cute oh now you Kido Kido [ __ ]
hard we'll get that later but let's say
it's like it's like like I always told
these kids it's like some but you've
been starving for [ __ ] 30 years and
then this one this is piece of bread out
here like your favorite piece of bread
or whatever that it is how you gonna
just take the piece of the corner and
not eat the whole thing
that's true cuz I like the crust it's
like that game when we were younger
people will just do just a tip man I
heard that game so much in middle school
hey guys they're like what does that
mean just a tip I can show you
no you can't don't show me that's like a
wild I didn't know that you still kept
your virginity till you were 30 years
old
wow that's you you are crazy yeah you
know it's funny cuz it's like uh this
dude asked me the other day he was fake
so like what if you stay single for the
next 10 years you still gonna keep you
fridge and I said hell yeah damn so he
that what he was trying to say is like
you trying to lose it to me or what no
cuz this atactic you know you can read
through people like saying so the one
thing is is like okay so the big girl
movement is becoming a little bit more
open-minded with certain men nowadays
okay before people weren't trying to
holler that much
Plus eyes girls in public like they you
were like or like they're doing now
before I was like all behind closed
doors like you could do now some people
got a little bit more courage and stuff
like this do literally told me more
cushion for the pushing I said excuse me
more cushion for the wet well why would
you say that you ain't pushing nothing
you ain't getting this bakery honey so
you don't have the key to this bakery
yeah that's so funny when guys write
[ __ ] like that like my my like I always
say this [ __ ] too like I just had a
conversation with the friend on this
podcast where people write [ __ ] right so
they'll write like you'll see it like
you see a beautiful woman on Instagram
right and then you see all these slobber
Ness [ __ ] right and they go oh
you don't know what I'd do with that ass
no you actually wouldn't know what you
would do with that ass I've seen I've
seen women write that I lust that after
two I'm like do that close [ __ ] find
his [ __ ] if she said to me [ __ ] me you
know what I would say I don't know what
to do I've never you have so much ass I
don't know what to do with it I don't
what am i what am I supposed to do with
this maybe I lay down and then you just
[ __ ] me and I'll see what happens
because I wouldn't know what the [ __ ]
you wouldn't you definitely would have
known what I do with it
but I am a little bit kind of ski I
shared this with my friends and I'm very
transparent about this day yeah I am a
little bit scared about sex only because
of the initial like everybody says the
first time hurts you I mean you would do
so it's not gonna hurt you but for me I
mean remember that D'Angelo song that's
exactly went through my head that's what
it felt like for me I'm just like for me
I just you know and I mean there's
probably gonna be some virgins who watch
this - our people who are contemplating
whatever I feel like do whatever you
feel you should do now within whatever
anybody else is trying to pressure you
to do but do what you feel that you
should do and for me I know that I just
want that one man in this whole entire
world and some people gonna sound crazy
yes but my flavor is I only want one man
inside of me that's it
I want one man to say that Dane I'm the
only man in this world that has been
inside of Amen
oh [ __ ] that's some mad confidence so
like and and it took some time to get
there but like I don't see myself
sharing myself with anybody else but
that one man yeah and you know when I
was younger too I feel like you know I
actually feel like it's going towards
this way which I prefer so when I was
younger I felt like over I say like 70%
of the dudes that I knew or it may be
even more already lost their virginity
by the time we were 15 yeah by the time
we were 15 14 they already lost their
virginity I was I was the late bloomer
and it's weird when I mentioned this
story or or I tell like a younger crowd
now they're like dude because I lost him
when I was 18 and I'm saying like I was
late and they're like that's not late
like we none of us lost our Virginia I
feel like kids are actually losing their
virginity later and later now because
people are being more open to bonding
they're talking about it like it's okay
you don't have to lose it like like your
virginity isn't a [ __ ] mole on your
ass you don't have to [ __ ] lose it
and nothing's gonna happen you know and
I mean exactly and it's just it's like
sex is put at such a high pedestal you
know like everything has to be sex like
even like when young boys talk they go
did you hit that hey wait yeah I'm gonna
be talking about something else
hidden in these bras that's what I want
to know weird too because you know a lot
of these young kids um you know I'm
saying this young kid as in a young
version of myself as well but we have
these conversations with these other
dudes that kind of talk a big game and
they really don't have game but they
talk a big game and it makes you feel
like that's the actual standard and it
[ __ ] a lot of people up specifically
young dudes like it [ __ ] them up let me
tell you this [ __ ] too like I remember I
was used when I was a young kid I
watched porn and I was like damn one day
my dates gonna be that big and it never
happened
so it's not supposed to be the size of
this table like what's going on here no
well but that's the kind of things that
cut will [ __ ] you up as a kid Yeah right
and it's so enjoy had no idea you were
keeping your virginity we talked about
before but it was in passing because the
thing is there was a time when I never
said it and then when I reached like 27
or so I was like why should I hide it
other people talked so much about their
sexuality
is never easy you know so why can't I be
an advocate for hey I'm keeping my
something like but what do you do though
let's say like for example right you
with the dude there's [ __ ] there's
candles of [ __ ] lit right we got some
Marvin Gaye in the background
something's happened you got dinner and
[ __ ] he slides over he puts his arms
around you puts his hands on your knee
cap Dave and then what do you do what
you do you just got like this little ice
bucket behind you and you throw it on
real quick where the [ __ ] you come with
that ice bucket like nothing you first
of all I haven't been on a date since
2013 yeah when someone was this one was
this guy the my ex I was mm that was old
like 2009 8 oh [ __ ] I've talked to dudes
but like a relationship wise dating
dating but well I need I was about to
say his name that's wrong but I've
spoken to [ __ ] you up guy between
between you know 2011 and 2013 but like
2014 I haven't been on a date since 2014
why I don't know just not you just you
just don't want that [ __ ] in your life
right now
well I've taught okay so I tried tinder
I tried coffee meets bagel yeah I tried
OkCupid there's one more I can't
remember but everybody the thing is is
everybody gets to a point where they
just want to have sex and that's not
what I'm doing even on coffee meets
bagel I heard coffee meets bagel wasn't
even like that coffee meets bagel wasn't
like that but then there were some dudes
on there who were just trying to smash
and that's not what I'm just that's a
tender thing though tinder oh my gosh I
was on tinder for three months and every
day I'm like okay this is going good two
weeks in whoo and then one dude was like
oh let's finally meet up I was like fine
I was like let's meet up by the SC area
okay oh no I was thinking more of like
you can just come over to me and my
mom's house you know what the [ __ ]
hell no I've never met you why would I
come to your house is like well I was
thinking we could watch movies and cook
and cut you never listen chill we ain't
doing that nah he was like we should
come over we gonna meet at my mom's
house yes just said you live with your
mom he rephrased it where he said we
just go to my mom's house no ma'am I
live with my mom yeah would you like to
come over as she watches us [ __ ] is that
what he's saying you [ __ ] yeah he's
just it's weird cuz like I get different
approaches but I always feel like even
now before you so really bother me yeah
cuz like everybody around me like out
here in LA all of my friends are mostly
male so like all my male friends uz ed
the Khalif Paul everybody's in
relationships and so used to really
bother me like hey how's everybody else
following final relationships and I'm
not but now I'm at the point like when
it happens it happens
I still put myself out there yeah but I
know what I don't want and so but you
know when I first met you did I have a
girlfriend I didn't know you did it yeah
but you weren't dating yeah I was dating
a lot but I wasn't in like long
committed relationships for a very very
long time
like it wasn't really something that I
wanted it's just when Mariel came around
I thought she had something very special
she loves she loves you yeah so like the
crazy thing is is like with her like I
wasn't planning to be even thinking
about serious relationship I hit 30 yeah
so around this time so I was like oh
maybe then I'll start thinking about
serious relationship because it wasn't
something that was ever I just didn't
want it like I didn't understand it's
because I didn't want to talk about that
demon cat I can't loves you though BEC I
see yeah but I wasn't thinking about a
serious relationship and it just kind of
happened in you know up before that
point it was just kind of like I'm just
gonna date around see what happens right
and I really wasn't looking for love at
all and sometimes it just kind of falls
into place and when you feel that you
feel and if you don't you don't and I
think the hard part is that people
sometimes tries to they try to get like
a puzzle piece that doesn't fit into
something that doesn't work right so
because some people just get desperate
they just they just prefer any type of
companionship versus finding somebody
that really fits them you better say
yeah and I see it all the time they go
they get with this person and they kind
of check off this list and I always say
this about relationships you can have a
set list about what you think you like
about somebody I'll tell you something
else they're gonna prove you wrong they
won't check all that list but for
summers you still gonna love them and
that's the hard part that's the people
don't understand that like even with
Muriel even with me what I had this
checklist of everything that I wanted
out of a girl and it wasn't the Korean
girl it was a it was a fat booty Puerto
Rican girl and you know it didn't happen
that way right yeah and so because
people don't fit into this checklist
they try to find somebody that does fit
it and even when they do fit that
checklist they find out there's
something they kind of force themselves
to be in this relationship because
they're like on paper this person's
perfect yeah this person I said that
this person would be perfect so why
don't I love this person they kind of
stay in this long-term relationship
because they think that there's
something wrong with them yeah it's not
but and then a lot of people also
compromise yeah I'm I'm not in with that
[ __ ] dude like I really I'm really not
into compromising and and that's why I
feel like I'm I've been single for so
long because I'm not willing to
compromise like some of my cousin's have
even said recently because you know
they're all getting engaged they're like
well why don't you try this person all
right he should do this all right
I mean does he really have to you know
wait for sex I'm like hell yeah he got
away for sex like I'm not having sex
with so it just any and everybody this
ain't open bakery
let me i'ma let y'all know right now
these cinnamon rolls and croissant
everything is not for everybody
croissants mother is you know nice warm
if flakey we not will know him that's
not a flaky but say nice and warm nice
and warm most nice crust on the outside
but you know like it's not for everybody
and so I don't I don't want to
compromise in that but I do believe that
you know God will give me the desires of
my heart and the desires that I'm
looking for and I'm pretty sure it's
gonna happen yeah I mean there's
there's no race to this [ __ ] exactly so
and that's another thing especially
coming it from an African family I'm
thirty 31 this year in the father what's
up I should they say T okay for
Christmas I you know I was my first time
going home in like a year to for
Christmas and so they're like mmm Emmett
cuz the the way you say in my language
is a man I ain't meant and so delay I'm
in and I'm like yes
so you haven't brought anybody back with
yourself here I was like what do you
like well you mean auntie you haven't
brought anybody I'm tired of seeing you
come here by yourself and I was like
what you trying to say like I
you're not giving young go okay you know
I usually just brush it off but then
like mom I might have a specific uncle
i'ma say his name because he knows he's
out there my uncle Chris is extra so he
be like you don't have a boyfriend
no okay so you have a boyfriend like you
know you're not getting any younger and
so and I understand they just want me
want to see me in love I get it some of
them are just like you're 30 you're
gonna be 31 and I was like so you know
it's also an older generation too so an
older generation they they kind of did
everything a little bit earlier than
yeah right so they got married when
they're like 22 had kids when the 24 25
but my mom she had be when she was like
34 oh wow yes she did my mom's uh my
mom's a cradle robber dude she's like
she's like seven years older than my dad
dude my dad's a grave robber and she's a
cradle robber the youngest I ever even
look like at any type of dude I was like
maybe four years younger he was fine and
he was so much her for his age I even
had to be like dang you a baby but then
you ain't a baby so it's like so usually
I don't understand how you stayed a
virgin
you [ __ ] got some you got some unholy
thoughts don't we all know you're also
on you guys's radio self you know what
I'm really curious about specifically
now that you actually brought that up I
guess I don't really think about a lot
of stuff that that isn't really talked
about in the church like for example
like like I always wondered to like if
some of these girls like masturbated
like within church because they always
acted like they didn't they're like no I
don't do that type of [ __ ] yeah they
would openly be like no I don't do that
type of stuff I'm like really like that
oh because a lot of my other friends who
didn't go to church that are females
they talk about it openly
yeah and they open they they're so open
about their sexuality like yeah I
masturbate yeah but some yeah the thing
is is this is the problem that we have
in the church but older church I think
the younger Church the people who are
like our age and getting older they're
being becoming a little bit more vocal
with stuff but the church has this I
don't know it's kind of like this
mentality of judgment and so some people
feel like their sins aren't equivalent
to your sins so if you're doing a sexual
sin you're going straight to hell
like Hellfire you know type of thing and
that's why we we don't want to talk
about it because these are real issues
most of the time with people and and you
know everyone has their own reasoning
but most of the time with people
masturbate there's something that
they're making up that masturbation for
there's a loneliness or there's mmm
they're they they're longing for
affection in some type of way you'd be
surprised with a guy though waiting long
for nothing
well I'm just trying to get my homework
done yes you know you don't eat let me
take some about doing in his dick all
right but most annoying thing about a
dude is the fact that our penis controls
everything at a young age I'm not even
[ __ ] I'm telling you right now I'm
telling it's the hormones I'm telling
you right now I could go beat off in the
bathroom like it's nothing I'm not
thinking about [ __ ] I'll just knock it
out and I'll come back and I'll solve a
quadratic equation cuz now my mind is
clear okay like your mind is cloud it's
[ __ ] annoying sometimes too like I'll
be doing work around
jackoff real quick say why cuz I can't
think yeah boom and I guarantee you help
me masturbate two times in a row I'll
[ __ ] figure out how to cure cancer
right now I'll do it right now that's
how that's how clap your [ __ ] mind
gets I'm not even kidding you like guys
don't really have in my personal opinion
X is not even my personal opinion any
dude can attest to this [ __ ] guys when
they masturbate it's not like a whole
ordeal there's no emotional attachment
to it it's just that my dicks hard bop
bop get it out the way wow I didn't know
that yeah it's it's not that this whole
ordeal about we don't gotta lie to
[ __ ] Canada set that aside get the
mood going like we're not it's not even
but you don't so when it happens y'all
don't think about like is there a reason
why it's frequent you understand we're
young it's it's it's a it's a natural
animalistic thing that we are trying to
fight so in my purse what I see it as is
this it's like we're animals right and I
think for the male thing is that as
animals we're trying to literally put
our seat in everything and so for us as
humans we have like a higher intellect
and we we generally don't need that
right we don't need to populate the
earth with everything like we don't need
our genes to survive that long but we
still have those instincts so for dude
we just have we reproduce even
consistently all like 1 million we got
but Jillian's right and women have a
certain set of eggs and that [ __ ] just
releases for us our semen just continues
over and over and over we could have
kids till we're like 50 or 60 years old
as long as we get our shade but my uncle
just had a baby and my uncle's like
about to be like 65 Dan he's got a daddy
grandpa no like bruh like when my cousin
grows up I pray my uncle oh he won't be
he's 65 yeah cuz he's older than my dad
my dad turned 61 this year damn I didn't
he's good listen my daddy is
good-looking and my Mama's gonna be 57
this year you know looks so good
she looks young that's why I'm gonna
look I mean people think I'm 16 you do
your mom has a type of energy dude like
I tell you like it's so funny when
when you were doing the whole refresh
event and I saw your mom and I was like
damn dude she looks very nice but she
look like she killed me at the same time
she just has one of those presences like
I'm so glad she's on my side she looks
like she's so close to God she could
literally just start stepping on air and
just go to heaven real quick I've got a
question to come right back down
yes that's what your mom looks like
that's what your mom looks like [ __ ] you
know I'm not even sure I'm not [ __ ]
with you I swear thought your mom did
this she was like disaster okay when
people say they do and they're talking
to God your mom is literally talking to
God
yeah my mom now see a baddy does she see
she's close to God for like that one man
is heaven saying yeah it's so funny you
know when I was cracking up about though
during the whole refresh thing was that
your mom was gassing you up so much
right she goes she goes she's just
talking about this is my Anointed One
and I'm like damn what about all the
other kids say a damn word about all the
other kids she just said like this one
right here everybody else but this one
and I was like I wish we recorded that
[ __ ] instead of talking siblings like my
brothers in my sister they yeah but no
my mom she's she's amazing I learned a
lot from her and she's just yeah it's
funny because like every time she comes
to LA people call her Queen cuz we went
to church and she walked in and so they
were like yo your mom is like y'all know
what you watched coming to me exactly
and they were waiting for the Queen's
come - oh yeah my mom her booty big so
what my mom what she swishes and so all
my friends was like damn oh by the way
this is my mom got that you know she's
in Nigeria right now I'm actually tell
her to bring some back yeah
get one for Paco Spaulding doing Oh cuz
there was only four yes I gotta get one
for Paul oh this is awesome I just try
not to wear this in public cause it
always starts up a conversation yeah I
need to get you a long-sleeve one like
the one that goes up to the neck yo that
looks so fly on you that's good this
chest right here people be asking too
much questions they like you going in
for surgery or what you know afro
afro-asian you know what's so funny when
Z gave this to us it was at this brunch
spot and then there was this other lady
who's a black lady she came up she goes
oh my god that is so beautiful I was
like this [ __ ] straight from the
motherland this is real real no yo I'm
so glad it's funny because I didn't
think you were gonna pick that one I
thought you're gonna pick the green one
this one was the biggest one o at the
time so the other ones were smaller
mm-hmm so now it's kind of baggy on yeah
but this [ __ ] feels good I can't wait
till this shit's like in fashion fashion
because a hundred percent know it will
be and this can cause a lot of Twitter
drama but people don't understand how
comfortable this [ __ ] is it's so
comfortable first of all if we start any
Twitter drama with you or Instagram
drama just let direct them to me I will
because I'm the one who gave it to Dave
and y'all stop hatin so chill out my
best friends were whining this [ __ ] to
you I got so mad at him I was like by
the way my other friends got me a
dashiki before you did [ __ ] tell
him he need a step up to our play no
game I say I'm gonna do something imma
do it the [ __ ] was so nice I was like oh
my god people don't know they don't
realize how comfortable this is yeah and
it looks so dope yeah people don't
realize oh if you have a hat all right
dad that would be so close and I would
and I would wear Korean [ __ ] but we got
18 layers to our clothes so it's like
our traditional guard is called a humble
that [ __ ] got humble humble it's nice
like 16 [ __ ] layers I mean it's heavy
so it's not the same as Y Z's people
know these people [ __ ] way different
they got a little [ __ ] yeah please on
the Association yeah yeah how most have
like a
a lot of layers to it's a whole ordeal
to wear but then I heard like in Korea a
lot of like fashion people are trying to
modernize that [ __ ] really so if they
modernize it out I would rock that [ __ ]
but as of right now you ain't got [ __ ]
on this no you need to go like whenever
you and Tim do a food thing you need to
get all decked out I hate two-tone wear
and just do I would [ __ ] love that
[ __ ]
welcome to San foods [ __ ] do
that [ __ ] so bad yo you gots to do it
like you and Tim do y'all's native
clothes and just you know what you know
what's so interesting that like because
my best friend's Rwanda he's African
like I grew up around his family so much
and a lot of people didn't get this and
specifically I was telling a Mariel
about this it's like America sees
Africans and black Americans as the same
thing but it's culturally so [ __ ]
different and people it's so weird how
they how they can't see that because
it's not even African and black that's
different it's immigrant mm-hmm
immigrant mentality is different from
bred American yeah and that's like the
biggest difference that I would see so
like when I was telling Mary oh but she
didn't really get it she was what do you
mean I was like well I was like Gobbo
he's Rwandan but a big part of him also
relates to him being a black American I
think that's just because of how America
sees him as well and probably how he
sees himself too because he doesn't
really speak like can you go on in and
stuff like that yeah but he's still
ethnically Rwandan but how everybody
else views it more the world views them
is as a black American yeah because when
you're not talking even if they don't
see your your license they're they're
gonna think you're a black man yeah
the only time they see you unless you
have like tribal marks like my mom does
or my sister has tribal marks
oh really because my sister was actually
born in Nigeria I'm the first one that
was born here and then my brothers after
me were born here oh wow yeah so like
unless you have tribal marks and you
know what tribal marks are you be like
oh you kind of look like they'll say
exotic but it's true because like even
at home back at home
that's Nigeria you know enter the doors
of
my house that's Nigeria when you leave
the house it's America and so there was
just weird like complex for me because
it's like I know that I could say half
the stuff my friends say that's cool
at home my mom was like what did you
just say you know that kind of thing and
so my dad will be like you know you're
not black American you're African so
there's this kind of thing like I think
with immigrant culture and I know that a
lot of us are trying to break it down
now because there used to be this divide
with African Americans and immigrants
yeah and so my dad I know for a fact my
dad had an issue with African Americans
when he first got here because African
Americans were like literally against
him they're like go back to Africa
you're taking all our opportunity and
you're getting this this and that or you
know whatever and the first person that
helped him was actually a Indian man oh
wow Indian man that was the first man
that helped him and he was working at a
Shell gas station when he first got here
he experienced racism from everybody
else yeah and he was just surprised that
a black man would talk to him in that
kind of way so there's a whole different
like complex when it comes to Africans
in Africa and it's weird because like I
would see that growing up and I would
hear these conversations is because it's
it's kind of like this so a friend of
mine told me about this [ __ ] to was how
she grew up with it in which how she
explained to me was when she was younger
because she's also she identifies as
being an African she goes I never really
understood she kind of empathized with a
lot of the racial stereotypes that
people were saying about black people
because she was an immigrant right so
shoes so people would say stuff like Oh
black people are lazy you know they have
all this opportunities because she would
hear this from her parents
well yeah but because that's it's an
African mentality like because I
personally for me like how I see it and
what I've seen African people and Cree
people are very similar work ethic wise
and so for them and her father was like
I work hard I'm an immigrant I came to
this country how do i how did I get all
this opportunity yeah but I hear these
people who are African American they've
been here for years and years and years
so
what's their excuse and so she kind of
grew up with that but what happens to
certain people I believe is that there's
a certain flip because you could say
that as much as you want in your own
world and as I mentioned before just
because you see yourself as a African
doesn't mean the rest of the world does
exactly and so when they get treated
poorly and they're like hold on a second
I'm not black American I'm African but
then they start to feel the weight of
those stereotypes and you don't have a
choice on whether you feel that or not
you could sit there and tell that person
you know I'm African I'm actually not
black it doesn't matter yeah and so so
when you feel that type of hatred and
you feel that type of just like
institutionalized hate yeah then it
starts to like flip these different gear
just like oh well maybe it's not because
of the whole thing of them being lazy
maybe it might be they might be at an
actual disadvantage yeah systematically
African Americans blacks whatever term
you want to use Negroes Negroes like all
this whole entire system was never built
for us even though the system was built
by us yeah you know this country the the
foundation was laid by slavery so now
it's like there's not there's not actual
old-school slavery like being in the
field of picking cotton
no now it's more of an institutionalized
prison system set up to be a detriment
to the black race yeah so it's always
something like people I remember one
time I seen I had to I had to catch
myself because you know that and this is
a whole nother thing that could be
talked about too but as a black woman
one of my counterparts was like well you
know to all of us women we all go
through stuff yeah we all go through
this is that we all are at a
disadvantage and this was before the me
to movement and all this other stuff and
I said I'm sorry you're white right it's
just like yeah I was like you go through
stuff but you're not gonna go through
what I go through as a black woman if
you went into the store I went into the
store and one of our friends that's
Asian and then another one of our
friends that's missing and that goes
into the store who's like who are they
gonna follow first yeah they're gonna
follow me yeah then they might follow
you know our Hispanic friend
then they might follow our Asian friend
they're not gonna follow you yeah so you
have to learn that already that I'm
already at the lowest of the low
yeah and you already have an advantage
even though yeah you're a woman and you
have issues with payment and stuff like
that but remember as a black woman a
minority woman us Asian women and
Hispanic women are already like Louis of
the low yeah and she could not wrap her
mind around it it's hard because people
don't experience it for themselves like
it goes back to and you know like I
don't like when I when I hear about a
woman like that like I don't feel any
hate towards her it's just like to him
like I wish I could just like take the
experience I wish I could take her out
of her body and put it into yours for a
second and then maybe she would
understand it a little bit and it's not
and it's not in a way to like hate on
hate on her it's just more like you just
don't know and sometimes like I I had
the biggest trouble with this and I had
a conversation with a with a lot of kids
about the school so I grew up in
Sacramento California right in North Cal
I should say the n-word like a
[ __ ] you know until this day it
slips out a lot just because I grew up
with it as a kid yeah I can tell you the
very first moment I actually used the
word like I'm talking about I was
chilling outside of my parents store and
I started my parents tour in South
Sacramento there used to be this this a
food truck called Mo's most and most
used to serve these like tacos these
Philly cheesesteaks and whatever so
every night around like 5 o'clock most
would roll up on the block
there was Lord Tony's artistic fingers
that was the Punjab star we used to call
Punjab I found out it's not actually
called pooja recently it only clicked
recently yeah we didn't know because
they call the Punjab too because we call
the puja to delight welcome to Punjab so
we didn't know I only found out recently
I was like oh [ __ ] it's not called
Punjab no but that's that's what we call
it on the block so and I remember that
all these like oh jeez used to kick it
outside and I was a young kid and this
kid this dude legit told me to say this
he goes he goes it was some blood I'm
like what's up man how you doing you
know I'm like super young and then he
goes what do you call me I'm like I
don't know I don't know your name right
he goes up will you call me I was like I
don't know he's out he said say I'm you
[ __ ] I'm like
well how's that okay I mean and I just
from that point on it was almost like I
felt like I was accepted into a group
right cuz I never really knew about that
when I was like eight or nine years old
I can't remember the exact number he
goes whenever you say you say what's up
my [ __ ] that's what you say yeah and it
became ingrained in me so much and it
just started becoming that was something
so casual and colloquial that everybody
said even a sacramental right now
anybody in NorCal to this day can attest
that I guarantee you in Northern
California people use that word more
freely than anywhere else yeah Mexicans
Asians black people whatever because it
was like a sign of endearment but what
people forget too is that that's not
your you don't get a passport all across
the world that's within your little
niche right so when somebody says hey
that word offends me you can't sit there
and argue with somebody and say well
so-and-so exactly you don't have that
pass and what I mean by that is a lot of
people don't understand the statement
when I say everybody's allowed to have
an opinion about something a hundred
percent but the difference is is whether
you how much you believe your opinion
matters on a subject that doesn't affect
you exactly exactly because it the thing
is just like when especially with the
word [ __ ] like a lot of people so I
used to live before I moved to where I
am now yeah I used to live in what they
call like little Tijuana of downtown
like my neighbors were all mess again
like down the block and so I was outside
one day and I was like you know what I'm
just gonna chill with these people you
know I see them spray-painting the
building all the time at least let me
get cool with you
like if something happens yeah I'll be
there and so I heard them calling each
other [ __ ] and I'm like I don't see no
[ __ ] around here dude and I was like
but why it's culture has taken that word
and made it hit yeah
and for people who are not black
whenever I put that like I told to do
stuff like y'all don't use that word
yeah they're like wow we I mean it's in
the music and so I was like yeah it's
it's in the music of a black person
saying it to their [ __ ] or whatever it
is but if you go down the street and say
that to somebody you gonna get cut yeah
so you need to be mindful like the the
word has become so loose
at the same time some people say it
because they're trying to be trendy or
hip yeah or in a term of endearment or
whatever maybe their usage but then it's
it's it's kind of hard because this work
came as something like hateful yeah yeah
yeah and so that is oh I've been in this
weird space with even me using the word
cuz I'm like dang like like I know like
oh this my [ __ ] but then at the same
time it's like bruh my ancestors whether
they were here in America or it's still
in Nigeria like they went through so
much stuff and would they want us to
call them [ __ ] like why would I
continue that so it's it's that whole
word I could talk oh it goes back and
forth exactly there's the other there's
the other opinion of well we took that
word that we made it positive so why
can't we use it you know exactly and
it's like it's like I see that point too
even then like okay like I will pose a
question to you like do people use Guk
all the time with you no they don't
because for us like I feel like nobody
has been able to turn that word into
something positive yet like and it
doesn't it just doesn't have that
cultural effect like for example the the
type of oppression like you know today
everybody's doing this [ __ ] now I
call it the oppression Olympics you know
what I mean and they're really trying to
like battle like black cultures like
well we're oppressed to hold on that's
true
but we're not talking about that like
people have to realize like for me and I
don't know if it's because I grew up in
Sacramento California my best friend's
African he's black American I don't know
why but I feel this way but I do feel
this way that you can't you that's not a
battle you're going to win in this
country specifically yeah the story and
the historical relevance and like pain
that comes from specifically slavery in
this country that african-americans feel
or black Americans feel is something
that you can't sit there and say well
I've been oppressed too because this
isn't like an oppression Olympics we're
not trying to joust to see these
oppressions more difficult right you're
not gonna win that battle yeah right so
it's such a weird subject for me so even
for me when I hear people use that word
and I sometimes hear people who in my
mind and I have no right to have an
opinion about it and this is where I say
like when my opinion is just my opinion
and it doesn't have any weight it's like
I'm like man I guarantee you never grew
up about a single black person but you
use that word yeah
no seriously and that's a date like some
white dudes other they were in a
convertible top and they were playing I
don't know if it was like ASAP Rocky oh
I'm not so many rappers out there and
then until the song says Nick and they
was just like bump up I like I'm no
happier with this color shirt on don't
have any black friends and y'all just
using it freely yeah so like it hurts me
cause it's like I don't know it's it
irks me because some people give passes
and then the moment somebody says [ __ ]
the wrong way cause it's all about
delivery yeah they get twisted yeah and
I'm like but you let them say this the
whole time in front of you so you have
to be mindful of what you're doing and
what you're saying and what you're
accepting yeah so you know just be
mindful I mean I usually I and I've been
using the word so much that I psychology
would not let me call you a ninja now
cuz I'm like I can't let me say ninja
its are men and it's so funny because
people write on comments is like well
you used to say back in the day and like
I did I'm not I'm not shying away from
that fact but you didn't blow up like I
did yeah what we run the people that I
did you don't go I'm the culture that I
did exactly and and I'm telling you
right be available maybe you'll say it
now that we're gonna catch it you will
catch me saying it yeah you will a
hundred thousand percent I'll put it out
there on this podcast right now you will
catch me saying that word because a lot
of my friends use it yeah and it will
slip out yeah just like every call s not
get it twisted every culture has a word
for some race like even for us like you
know some Nigerians they used to say
ching chong yeah when they're you know
but they're now they say [ __ ] oh yeah
like oh he was chinko and that could be
very derogative right so every culture
has it y'all just need to be mindful of
how you're using it and stuff like that
that's my biggest thing yeah so yeah
like every culture has that [ __ ] yeah
like I'm saying like it just is I'm
gonna say it again and it goes back
you can have an opinion about something
but just know whether your opinion has
weight on a subject that doesn't affect
you exactly cuz if you don't have the
weight bruh go sit down yeah cuz like
I've like I this this one kid came up to
me during a college show he goes yo man
like I just want to know what's your
opinion about you know saying the word
[ __ ] and I was like well first of all
bro yeah was he black he's Asian
also you asking the wrong person my
opinion doesn't matter
exactly it doesn't matter and the fact
that you think that I am some kind of
like pass for you like I could give you
this pass I'm the wrong person to ask
dude but we live in a culture and
especially a society now that we're
looking for passes from everybody yeah
everybody we're looking for validation
like okay well if Davis say Manama say
if Kim card but you know if one if Bart
is saying it okay I'm gonna see if make
up shameless doing this that I'm gonna
do like people are just like okay well
they're doing this I'm gonna do it nah
brah
make your own decisions that's what you
need to do instead of trying to have
somebody else lead the way for you who
you barely even know yeah and if you
feel weird about it now then you
probably shouldn't say it that's say it
again if you feel weird about it now
then you probably shouldn't thank you
that's what it is it is what it is and
bro I've always wanted to talk about
this subject but then you know people
always vitamins that has a little touchy
I'm like it's not touchy because that's
it's just truth to me and then I can
have a conversation with somebody if
like for example like I'll put it like
this if somebody came up to me he's a
black didn't he was like you know what
don't you ever use that word I probably
in front I was like I'll try my best not
you I'm not gonna sit and argue with the
guy he's not gonna it's like it's the
same way if he goes you know what if he
said came up to me and then he he said
something I don't know let's say like he
had an opinion about how Asian men
should be I'd be like the [ __ ] do you
know cuz you're not Asian
you're not a Asian dude so don't have an
opinion about how Asian masculinity is I
don't want to hear your [ __ ] opinion
about that [ __ ] it's not something that
you experienced so it works both ways
yeah you know and people just don't see
it for some reason some people are so
[ __ ] attached to that word and I
can't understand why well because the
thing is is though the word is rooted in
hatred yeah
and so whenever something that is rooted
in hatred comes up as a trend it is kind
of there's there's multiple aspects of
it people look at it as a mockery yeah
like oh I'm saying [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] now
you know and but it's nothing but to
some people it mean something yeah
because that's that strikes a chord
within us like it feels funny yeah it
feels funny cuz even me like even
sometimes like even when I I may use the
earth like somebody's like What's Up
[ __ ] to me and they're black like yeah
it's like cool the reason why we are so
happy we have so much candor with that
word now is because it's almost like
we're reclaiming it and we know the
strife that has come with it but if if a
white person or a Hispanic person if
somebody came up to me it's like what's
up [ __ ] I say what should you say
yeah yeah you trying to catch these
hands yeah because now it's like you
don't know the weight that comes with it
yeah you don't know the weight like the
first time somebody called me [ __ ] was
when I was in the sixth grade this guy
was making fun of me at lunch and so he
told his sister who's in the eighth
grade to come and like try to scare me
or whatever and I stood up and I said I
ain't scared of you like that and I
think we got a problem
we can talk about this after school and
like you know oh [ __ ] yeah so we had a
shouting match I didn't hit her nothing
like that but we ended up getting in
trouble yeah and her mom comes to pick
her up after the principal's office and
other stuff and her mom rose up they had
a green suburban I remember so vividly
her mom picks them up rolls him down he
had like red hair and his sister had
brown hair she's like is that the [ __ ]
that got you in trouble huh and I
remember I like I've especially as an
African child I've never heard anybody
call me that like I've heard call me
people call me African booty scratcher
stuff like that I was like okay whatever
yeah but like [ __ ] was like I hadn't
even know what that word was yeah so I'm
like what like this feels really bad I
started crying and I told my mom when I
go home even though I was already in
trouble for that but I was like mommy
she called me [ __ ] and she said what
my dad's I'm going up to that school
tomorrow yeah and my dad so the person
with the principal this the vice
principal is black the regular principal
was white but it was so weird and that
that's when the first time I felt the
hate of the word so I never used the
word up until like my mid-20s yeah it
just it there's hatred there because I
was like oh my gosh is she gonna follow
me going home and then like you know you
know I'm in Texas the KKK gonna come up
to our house and throw some you know
some cocktails and burn our house down
like you know I just don't know I was
scared yeah so a lot of times when
people hear that from another race
they're like oh snap
like what you trying to do like what are
you trying to say yeah so it's it's
touchy it's hard
but everybody just needs to evaluate
where why they're using that word and
there's it's just a weird need so like
like for example if like it's like a
blonde white girl was like okay well why
can't I use the word because I hear it
in music all the time and that's not
that you're not asking the right
question it's why do you need to say it
exactly
thank you that's the real question is
why do you need to why is it such a big
thing to you that you have to say it and
you and it's like well everybody else
guessed it well guess we'll welcome to
the oppression Club then if not you know
well welcome to a club where you mob
today welcome to the club where you
don't get to do something because this
the color of your skin then yeah welcome
well and it's not even something big
it's something so small very small and
they get so riled up after something so
small off of something so small and uh
don't get me started like it's not like
we over here buying our ways into
schools okay you know shade Oh
full house yeah I know why the house was
focus you had a full of money okay you
really want to do some damage give me
five hundred thousand of pay my student
on let me go
this house okay you over here it's not
like word is it's a word that they feel
like they get so mad I've literally see
people get red in the face because we're
like don't use that word why can't I use
it why are you so mad are you so mad
like what I don't get that part and I
started laughing because it's not
suppose it's not supposed to be funny
but I'm like I'm laughing cuz you dis
mad off of a word and I'm mad because I
just walked into the store and old girl
was following following me around trying
to act like oh do you need help I told
you three times I don't need help yeah
so you know it's like that kind of stuff
you want to have the privilege of being
mad for something small like that when I
don't even have the privilege of having
peace when I go to the store or I don't
have the privilege of having peace when
I'm driving down the street and two cops
are like side-by-side and they're
checking out my tags even though my tags
are valid yeah
you know so it's just like little stuff
like that is what pisses me off when it
when a specific race gets mad because
they can't use the word and it's weird
too cuz like I even think about it like
this in the sense of um like like in
white America right so it's weird how
even till this day people don't with all
the the knowledge and all the
conversation that's happening now with
it
they still don't understand that okay
well I heard this like Asian and Mexican
dude use it and you know people just
kind of shrugged it off they're not
black it's like but there is a
historical hatred that happened between
white Americans and black Americans so I
don't know about them but what I do know
is that well for some reason when you
say it hurts a lot more it feels weird
it feels a certain way even for me I'm
not even black but I feel weird about it
I'm like yeah something weird about you
saying it for some reason and I don't
know why I don't I don't know what it is
maybe like I said it's probably because
of the the neighborhood that I grew up
when I grew up around a lot of black
people yeah and so I get a taste of that
so it feels weird when it rolls off your
tongue because it's kind of like people
before you and we're not we're not
holding you to it against it like I'm
not hating you for it but that means
that you're not acknowledging what
happened before and now you you
this word that was used to ridicule
somebody to belittle them and now that
is cool okay so you get to do that when
it was cool then and you get to do it
now when it's cool now so so what's how
is that fair that it my thing is don't
you you get mad about the word but you
can't even understand when you're black
coworker comes to work especially a
black woman and they tell her oh you
need to press your natural hair yeah if
you can't even understand the
fundamentals of that alone you don't
even need to be using the word yeah if
you can't understand the reasoning as to
why we're mad when it comes to police
relations and black people don't use the
word yeah if you can't understand that
nine times out of ten if a black man is
driving a luxurious car and he's in a
all-white neighborhood more than likely
he's gonna get the cops called on him
you can't use the word like it's little
things like that like I'm like you you
don't understand the oppression just
like you were saying before you will and
more than likely they probably will
never understand the oppression at all
so I just I don't understand this notion
of bitterness or anger when they get so
mad when you tell them that they can't
do something oh you know why it's
because they've never been told that
they can't do anything and so that's why
when when they meet that type of
friction they're like oh wait you're
telling me I can't do something I'm
privileged I can do whatever I want no
you can't yeah and that's what it feels
like and you know I feel like anybody
who is a you know white American that's
listening to this it's not this is not a
negative conversation where I'm dogging
on like white Americans I'll you know
it's it's all good you know it's just
it's a frustration that people feel yeah
it would be nice if it was understood
yeah
and communicated that way but like I
said when you when you have a
conversation if somebody tells you how
they feel about something and you're
dismissive of it and you say you're just
being sensitive when you don't even know
what it's like it's kind of like then
what does this conversation go right
because for me to like and and I also
get a note of the extra what white
people to like they
annoy the [ __ ] out of meeting more they
pissed me off even more than like it's
like they try to you're not woke I mean
you understand history that's great you
know and you understand certain elements
of social social interactions and stuff
but some of them take it to the point to
where not all because I have some
friends who are why in their woke so I
don't want a blanket everybody but some
that I've met they legit think that
they're so woke that they know the
struggle yeah and it's like rachel
dolezal thank you that's one of them
because we don't you don't open the can
of worms
Rachel literally thinks oh oh I can be
black dinner that's why she turns her
skin she gets her hair braided whatever
black people can't become white there's
no choice and there's there's even a
hashtag you can see it on Instagram
there's some European white girls and
even some of them here they're they've
gotten so tan that they look like black
girls they're doing their they look like
black girls they get their hair braided
I kid you not if you did not see this
one girl exposed them and it was like
trending for like a couple months it was
like three or four girls they look black
like I'd even though they weren't black
until I saw a picture before and after
people want to be black because they
think it's trendy a lot of the times the
trends that's that that's hip and
happening in popular culture came from
black culture they want to be black up
into a certain extent until they need to
invest or until they need to get loans
or until they need to get that job or
that acceleration being black as a trim
but you don't want to you they don't
want to have all of the discord and the
the challenges that come with being
black look no shame to the Kardashians
but they got black bodies and everything
that they do is based off a black
culture but they're still white yeah
they still have the privilege of being
well there are many in but they have
your eccentric features that kind of
like they were they're not gonna get the
discrimination that black people get
yeah and so it's just it's this thing
like people want to soak it up and and
have this culture but they don't want
the things that come with it
Rachel can today she can stop tanning
and stop putting weave in her head and
she's gonna look like a white woman and
get all her privileges back yeah and
that's the weird feel when I saw a
picture of what she looked like before
that [ __ ] looked like a Puritan yeah
she turned by pure bred white yes you
were like straight from the waterfall
she's over here making wool blankets and
making her own butter she's got about
five sheep you know you know and you
know I guess like the one thing that I
did feel bad about for her was was how
bullied her kids were yes you know
that's kind of funny because our kids
are mixed-race yeah her kids are mixed
race kids and they kind of feel the
brunt of like her mom's choices which
which sucks you know yeah and I wish
like they would just leave those kids
[ __ ] alone yeah I don't like when
people bully kids at all
yeah like leave the kids out of it I
think that's what people I guess like
for me like I'm not a I don't like that
word culture appropriation cuz it's been
used so much they kind of lost all this
meaning but that's cultural
appropriation really means like picking
and choosing when you get to have the
benefits but you don't take all the
negative and all the almost stuff that
comes along with it and I think that's
definitively what cultural appropriation
is right yeah it's like you can say like
for example I guess like a hot trend of
modeling there's this girl that I met
through like on Instagram she's like
she's a really dope girl she's a model
friend of my friend Darian and she's
kind of upset about this trend where
these models are doing this they're
making their eyes slant do this though
they'll cover their face half and
they'll pull their eyes back and it's
like a trend right now like doing this
and is it like with the picture or like
they actually putting my hands like the
pictures like a modeling photo to think
like like Asian Asian eyes you know and
it's like a it's like a trend right now
and so if Asian people don't understand
what it feels like you know that's why
people had a I guess like a certain I
mean it was kind of extreme like the
whole dreads thing when they saw a white
person with dreads some people took that
really extreme but I could not kind of
understand why I felt that way because
it was like so I usually get made fun of
for that hair people said it was dirty
people
said it was raggedy as [ __ ] but now you
put it on and now you're this woke ass
person and you're a trendsetter so what
the [ __ ] well I don't get that [ __ ] you
know so it's good the same thing with
these Asian eyes when they people people
see this mmm so maybe that's what it
feels like yeah that the way they did
this particular race does this with
everybody they know what the black folks
they do with the Asian folks they do it
with Hispanic folks they do with the
Indians yeah I mean look at Redskins you
still haven't changed the name of the
football team yeah you know so it's it's
like I don't it frustrates me so badly
because it's like they don't care like
you can bring it up as much as you want
and they'll try to act like oh there's
where we're hearing you but you haven't
done anything yeah and I don't I don't
know where that culture came from where
it's like okay like for instance I was
so pissed off when Kim Kardashian posted
her shot day I do break it she was like
Oh spy um was it what's the girl's name
Billy or I forgot some white model from
like the 70s I said that girl that came
from Africa okay the Zulu people were
doing their hair like that and that's
the hairstyle she said oh you know I
love I think it's not Bojangles Lord I'm
thinking about it but yeah I'm like you
don't love that fried chicken joint yeah
like you know just like they've been
doing this page bo Derek here they go
you know they've been doing this for
ages with with minstrel minstrel see
like you know doing the blackface or
like when they wanted to portray Indians
in movies they would all like do like a
really tan Brown face and feathers in
there I just like it pisses me off when
I see stuff like I haven't seen that yet
so I know I will be infuriated by that
because it's just like you're doing this
whatever you doing that for it yeah I
don't know what's the point just like
with your lip injections y'all are
making fun of us Oh big lip in the big
booty and it's hot isn't that so funny
one remember like like people used to
make fun of that [ __ ] jokes I oh my
god look at her [ __ ] fat ass like it
was a bad thing and now it's a hot it's
looming gnashing at me my lips done
jay-z lips like what the heck this is
trendy now yeah you know and that's what
pisses me off man it's just I can't it
so it's a weird feeling man because it's
like everything that you were made fun
of before is now with a hot thing and
now you go from light you know people
sometimes see it as this is like well
aren't you happy cuz now like you're the
it thing but it's like no because now
it's like I feel like an object like I
feel now I get it was saying now I have
the polybius to be like objectified or
something like it's hard to explain to
somebody you know yeah I don't want to
sound like somebody that's complaining
about this stuff but as I get older I do
think about this stuff and like things
just don't roll off my shoulders like it
used to yeah but the thing is is I'm not
gonna feel happy yeah because I'm not
benefiting from this mm-hmm
they're benefitting from it they can
have the hairstyle and then go back to
their normal lives and they're fine yeah
but this is who I am my hair is kinky
yeah okay but if you're telling me the
press I remember I was trying out right
after I got out of grass guess see I was
trying out for like I wanted to do TV
reporting instead of print reporting
yeah
and so this lady told me straight up
there's a really big brand that does
like placement and styling for on-air
reporters and so you know I showed her
like my portfolio am i real and
everything she was like well if you want
to be on TV you're gonna need to lose
like 80 pounds yes and you need to do
something with your hair yeah I was like
like what with my hair like you know I
can put in a bun I did she's like now
you're gonna have to straighten that and
in my mind I'm like what's the problem
with my natural hair yeah literally and
so it that blew me away cuz I've never
experienced that kind of professional
like prejudice or that professional like
racism and so I went to the bathroom and
I bawled my eyes out yeah
and so there was a reporter that was
hearing me crying and she was like girl
do what you need to do she was like you
know the game has not changed for years
and years if you need to wear a wig for
now
and then later on down the line you know
you can wear your natural hair but just
do what you need to do and I that even
hearing her that even made me mad
because she she because she yeah she
gave in and this is a well-known
reporter and I'm just like I get it but
when are we gonna stop like for ooh you
are hating on me because my hair is
kinky yeah and y'all telling me that I
now I have to subject myself to your
American standards yo people didn't even
understand this concept I actually wrote
a sketch for Khalif called let me touch
afro Oh remember that yes I remember so
people don't people thought it was
hilarious but that was I wrote that
sketch for Khalif because I always heard
that [ __ ] growing up and I always say
this I always shout out my hometown
Sacramento because of how culturally
diverse it is because a lot of the stuff
that people talk about I wouldn't be on
their wavelength like they didn't
understand what was the plot why can't I
ask the touches here because he's not
your [ __ ] pet that's one it's just
it's hair it's his hair mmm
like even like so Merritt I like I love
Meryl to death but she didn't grow up
around a single [ __ ] black person so
for her you know she's just you know for
Khalif cuz he's my he's like one of my
closest friends she's like she's like
League like you mind if I touch your
hair you know and I told her I was like
it's okay because Khalif were close like
that but in general you shouldn't do
that like it's not something that you
should do and for EM she's she's a
[ __ ] intelligent woman so she was
like I understand she gets it you know
but for her it's it's just yes at least
she [ __ ] has some people just go up
and touch it because I smacked this
woman's hand one day yes I sure did last
year I had a afro it wasn't my hair but
you know it was a weave but she it was
ready buddy it's your [ __ ] hair yeah
I bought it so it was real big this
woman like I'm helping her later though
you know I'm at work and uh yeah okay
all of a sudden I feel something in my
head she put her hand in my head I said
excuse me
no you don't do that only just wanted to
touch I was like would you like it if I
started doing this to you and I started
putting my hands all up in her hair like
oh my gosh your hair so straight yeah
other stuff I said oh wow yeah you don't
do that I'm not your pet this
my head you don't touch me without
asking exactly and it's so weird how
even at that moment when you said excuse
me what are you doing
she thought that oh I was just touching
your hair was an acceptable response and
then she thought oh it's gonna be cool
if I say I was just touching your hair
it's like if I was chilling right and
then some some lay your dude came up and
touched Mario's hair because they
thought it was so silky I'll grab that
motherfucker's and I'm snap his [ __ ]
hand you don't [ __ ] touch it without
ask exactly you know it's the same
concept so I'm saying that that's like
this huge disconnect and I've never been
able to understand that because number
one my parents don't abuse applies or so
I grew up around black women 20 I'm
still waiting on my hair yeah let me
know what you wanna pet smite retired a
couple years 24 inch 24 inch what I
don't know I got to think about Peruvian
you want that Indian remy hair try to
get that silky silky your hair got
[ __ ] expensive as [ __ ] yes
so like I'm gonna do some hair talk real
quick but so when I was working to my
parents throw you up and run it [ __ ] but
I remembered that was just out of
nowhere the hair prices skyrocket and
you know what [ __ ] happen [ __ ] why
people started to understand yo I don't
have to do my actual hair and grow it
out just putting clips and extensions on
yeah and then the price went oh we used
to have like the $7.99 packs is our
human hair wasn't human hair bland it
was the real thing I mean hair and it
wasn't as good as some of the other
stuff but if people wanted something
real quick that was cheap because by the
way when you buy hair that's not already
the cost the process cost me more more
so you got to buy this expensive ass
hair gotta buy the needle to do the
thread yeah exactly and so like I just
remember the prices skyrocketed
everybody woman they were mad at us like
oh you trying to [ __ ] profit it's
like no I don't think you realize this
[ __ ] got hella expensive yeah like our
$7 packs became $15 packs are $10 packs
were not 25 bucks and it was just the
same margins for us but we just had to
up it up and people didn't get it they
thought we were trying to like oh like
oh you [ __ ] trying to profit us
no it's like no [ __ ] I got this mug in
like thrift store clothes I'm balling
buffer
I guess the same thing will wid culture
too because now say everybody's wearing
wigs yeah I'm telling you real quick
when Beyonce I forgot what performance
it was but she had that lace front wig
lace front wigs blew the [ __ ] up and
that's all everybody wanted from us
because back in the day it was just pro
style gel and a drawstring pony
it was easy back then it sure was like
you don't have to do all this oh my gosh
I need to put you know the glue right
here and lay the lace down put down the
baby like it's just too much nowadays I
was the lace funding they gave the baby
hair so it looked like it came from your
scalp even though we all know that's a
place we know that's the place they come
from your scalp did that [ __ ] would be
so funny cuz like I remember uh I would
hear people like specifically when I was
in school because you know people don't
expect there's like Korean Asian kids
who have grown up around black women
with black women hair props and
everything no I just hear some [ __ ] that
used to crap me on be like damn this
girl she snapped that [ __ ] on real quick
yeah it took two seconds no cuz I
changed my hair like maybe every two
weeks and so I know my coworkers are
like damn oh then one co-worker used to
be like oh you mean your hair grow a lot
overnight you know that I use a weave in
my eyes I'm trying to make comments we
know it's a weave okay that's [ __ ]
honey man you don't did you ever think
that you were gonna marry a black woman
I did mmm I actually thought that uh I
probably would have ended up with either
a Vietnamese girl a black woman or
latina girl I never thought I'd be with
a Korean girl and eat my best friend
assume that I was probably end up with a
black girl Wow yeah so did I I legit did
though I didn't think out I would have
always thought Oh Dave's gonna be with a
Korean girl Oh Justin right when I first
met you I was like either a Korean girl
or I could see you with somebody who's
mixed yeah Korean and like Hispanic or
something yeah like I well I think it's
just like I don't know like it was so
weird for me growing up just because I
think I grew up around so many black
women I just assumed you know maybe
but then like I think um like for once I
think people do get it twisted like I
know we always hear these these comments
about Asian parents and how they don't
like black people where my parents on a
black piece of plaster what if they
didn't not like black people why the
[ __ ] would they open the black Petes
blessed oh yeah that'd be the dumbest
[ __ ] thing on earth yeah so for me it
was just hard culturally for my mom so
because family is so important for me
and for me to keep my culture alive
specifically in this country where I
feel like it gets diluted because people
tend to be ashamed of it yeah if I did
marry a black girl she would have to
know how to speak Korean
that was a period in the story so it's
like you know yes yeah so if i if i did
i guarantee you if i met that one
finance black girl and then she spoke
Korean fluently I would have chased it
to the ends of the earth because I never
saw it you know you know I'm saying but
like that was just such an important
thing for me was for me to preserve my
culture because I want my kids to know
how to speak Korean I don't want to just
die with me yeah you know and so a lot
of the girls that I ended up dating I
would just bring it up casually like yo
so what would you think about learning
like I can't learn language I'm like
well this conversation is over
yeah I feel the same way the first dude
that I ever liked when I was in
elementary school he was Italian hmm and
so I was I will you know I'm open but
now I I desire a Nigerian man it's
something about it you know and I think
also too because I think the the
beautiful thing about your family
specifically is that you guys came to
this country but you didn't lose your
ethnic identity and that happens a lot
because you get scared of persecution
bigotry so you tend to put who you are
and what you grew up with and what built
you as a human being to the back because
you're afraid of that [ __ ] but then like
I said your mom has conversations with
Jesus like this so she is scared of [ __ ]
my daddy I'm trying to have your dad
cradle me rock me to sleep marry you
guys I'll be so happy I'm telling you
man like that's that's that's the great
thing too and you you find out when you
get older how all that stuff bleeds into
your life yeah important it is to very
important you never know that when I was
a kid I would have never thought how
important it was for me to relate
to me being Korean yeah I didn't realize
how often I use I didn't realize how my
behaviors are so Korean I'm super proud
to be cramming a lot of jokes about
Korean people that's my culture but I'm
proud to be creative I'm very proud to
be Nigerian but when I was younger I was
ashamed yeah because people will call
you African booty scratcher and then I
go back to Africa and do you guys talk
like this all the time and I was just
like no we don't do that I don't want to
be African I remember I came home that's
on my mouth I don't want to be African
and more it should be just go tell your
dad what you just said my dad said why
would you even say that they're just mad
because they're not as smart as you okay
babe I feel like your parents were so
like emotionally supportive anywhere
they they like they built you up strong
because you do have a very very strong
presence like when you walk in a room
people notice you so I'll call you
African sunshine like you walk in and
there's always I'm I know that you
definitely go through your own things
and I know that you have your own
personal issues but you are somebody who
doesn't put that on to others right so
you learn how to deal with your problems
and when you're around people you you're
very like socially aware which a lot of
people cannot do guys girls it doesn't
[ __ ] matter if they have a bad day
the whole world is gonna feel it that
because I know that you you know you
went through a lot of things especially
moving to LA but I wouldn't have known
unless like Zee mentioned it yeah and I
wouldn't have known this stuff yeah cuz
you remembered that was there's a time
when I was living with Z for like what -
I don't even know that [ __ ] yeah
that's so [ __ ] wild to me I didn't
know and like Z kind of helped you out a
lot stuff so that's probably boy you
guys bond came through yeah that's so
[ __ ] crazy you mom must love Z man my
mouse we pray for a wife for him to
recompose like Massey blame she looks
poor recently yeah but she she loves
eBay that's her same that's like that's
my same she's always asking about him
have you spoken to Z and there's
something because my mom's I think she's
coming next month she's like yes I need
to
for him heinous jollof rice I was like
uh what about me I don't see him all the
time I was like Oh ma'am you do not see
me all the time that's so [ __ ] funny
there are some times treat your friends
better they treat you they shall do and
they will embarrass you they will
embarrass you that's when they want to
bring out all the stories about how you
did this and I'm like why are you
telling him that why you tell there's a
few people on this earth where when I
Kirsten I act up you just cuz it's how I
grew up it's hard for me to change it I
always think in the back of my mind I'm
not even [ __ ] [ __ ] you I'm like
damn I weigh men's boxing this year oh I
feel like the weight of her judgement on
my back I feel like she watching this
[ __ ] I'm like I don't curse all the time
it's just giggles who does it your mom
has the same the same type of like
warmth and confidence you definitely got
that from your mom
you're definitely extension of your mom
cuz your mom when she was at the refresh
event she commanded a presence that I've
never felt before
I saw a golden line behind it she was
great I'm like are you still doing the
whole Refresh event
yeah I've taken a break just because I
like you said that there's a lot of
stuff that I was going through I'm just
like finding my own beauty and so I
found myself like refreshing other
people but I was feeling depleted ah so
I literally just got this tattoo that
says beautiful goddamn you got a tattoo
you're my best friend just got a tattoo
that son of a [ __ ] we supposed to get
one together dumbass
this is my second Linda I'll really have
another one where you got the other one
in okay no no that's okay it's on my hip
okay whatever
amen that's your side ass
sigh - that's called hip mal it's called
sigh - that's the hill let me tell you
something just because you say it is God
knows God knows what side ass is but
yeah so you know I'm going on this
self-love journey because you know and
you could relate like being a plus-size
person your whole entire life you know
you people always tell you that you're
beneath ya and so you know a lot of
people have told me well maybe you would
have somebody if you were smaller and so
like you know I not heard that yeah and
so like people have been saying even now
that I'm getting older they're like oh
you know and I'm you know thank god I've
lost like 50 pounds that's fine but I
descended for myself
yeah right but even then like in the
beginning when I started I was okay yeah
I'm a lose weight so I couldn't get a
husband and I'm like nah that should not
be your goal yeah because you're gonna
be chasing a satisfaction that is rooted
in sorrow or rooted in judgment and so
you know this whole I went 29 years not
thinking that I was beautiful well and
so you know I've been on this journey
now just trying to tell myself okay you
are beautiful like you are an image
you're made in God's image so you're
beautiful and so I'm trying to see
myself the way that God sees me yeah and
so that's when I got this I actually got
this it's peeling so yeah I got it last
week Saturday you know I'm telling you
man like that I definitely understand
what it feels like I was a big guy
before majority of my life you know I
actually had the opposite of you like I
thought I was beautiful constantly and
yeah and that's one thing out I've
always wanted to tell you that like
David for every time I was around I was
like man I need to get confidence like
Dave yo Mike for a real for I remember
one time this was like I think maybe
like 2014 or fifth no I didn't meet you
14 2015 we were talking I think we were
all like like ZZZ how some reality out
to eat in k-town yeah and you're like a
man why you ain't got no man yeah and I
don't know and so I said I don't know
maybe I'm not pretty enough and you
looked at me he said the I'm telling you
what you are but wait why are you saying
that and so that was the first time I
ever met correction and so I was like I
didn't know what to say and you're like
no you are a bomb-ass woman this is a
man and I was just say wow thank God I
need that kind of you know confidence
from Dave because I always tell people
this man like you know the whole world I
feel like this whole world is designed
to break you down I always tell kids
this so if everybody else is objective
is to tell you something that you're not
the the first source of negativity can't
be from you you have to be the first
person everyday to tell yourself that
you're something special because
everybody else is gonna do that yeah
constantly so if you're the first person
to tell you tell yourself that you're
not beautiful then what's gonna happen
you're already at a disadvantage yeah
and I found it so difficult when people
would do that to themselves it's like
how can you expect other people to love
you when you don't love yourself that is
so [ __ ] hard yeah and and one of my
good friends just posed that to me like
a couple weeks ago and he was like
talking to me he was like what's going
on cuz I feel like something's going out
you've been real quiet and so I told him
and he was like you and we were talking
about refresh cuz he was like oh what's
what's the next refresh event I wanna
help like you know whatever and I was
like oh I'm putting a hold on it because
I feel depleted and then I'm just I'm
going through a lot of stuff with like
my self-image and stuff and he was like
you won't be able to receive love if you
can't even love yourself yeah and that
blew me away cuz of my day and I'm like
praying like god I can't wait for me to
get it man and oh you know that and then
God's just like bruh you can't even love
yourself how will I you pray for this
perfect not perfect look but you pray
for this love that stretches you that
brings fullness to you that you can see
like somebody else's flaws and still
love them and all this other stuff but
you can't even see your own flaws and
love yourself yeah you can you know and
so that's what I've been on you know
recently but I'm gonna bring refresh
back in the summer yeah but right now
I'm just working on yourself it's it's
it's it's super important like you
the same way I can give like a bus to
where I'm like it's like permission to
tell myself that I'm beautiful if
somebody's gonna call me ugly I'm with
all myself ugly first you don't get me
first
like for me to like I had the hardest
time losing weight cuz I thought I was
fit but really I thought I was fit I
said athlete I said I can't believe I'm
not in the NBA right now I take LeBron I
snap those angles too highly of myself
but then my heart murmur and my have
said otherwise they don't make xxx cells
like they used to huh
why's it so tight well I don't know
maybe I still feel like they've been
making size and smaller nowadays I blame
my dryer real quick I was like this [ __ ]
excuses and then finally like it hit you
you know what I talk about the story too
much but it's just as I'll tell you this
but I found out that I was fat just
because of what Muriel said to me and
she was almost in shock about how
judgmental I was of other fat people
because I will be sitting thought we
were sitting eating and there was the
this couple of fat people that would
eaten that's the minimal mmm many of
those fat people just munch in a way and
she looked at me she goes you're fat
how's that mean I'm fat I was like they
fed yeah I'm not fat she goes you're
fatter than them like house I join your
period or something was going on are you
tagging me like what's going on and I
like and all this [ __ ] started clicking
dude I was like oh [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] fat
yeah like I knew I was fat but I didn't
think I was fat fat yeah you know like
cuz I just always thought highly of
myself yeah but then I started realizing
you I have sleep apnea you know my
skin's terrible my knees hurt my back
hurts I'm like now it's not a matter of
opinion this is just fact but you are
super out of shape and you got to get
this [ __ ] together exactly and so it's
just it for me that's another thing too
is cuz like I have symptoms of sleep
apnea too and that that was where I was
like I can't
yeah like I think that my heaviest
weight was 313
oh sure yeah a Dane
you know I'm proud of you right there
you said yeah that's a very big thing
right there because you would ask I
would ask a lot of women like what cuz
they wouldn't talk to me about wanting
to lose weight I'm like what do you
weigh right now there I can't tell you
yeah right now I'm 257 that's amazing
so I'm yeah so I still want to lose like
I know they're like 75 that's very
doable Wow it took me like people are
like some people I have a cousin who
lost like like 60 pounds in last like 7
months
Andrew cocaine's a hell of a drug no but
like for me I've done it gradually
because whenever I lose weight fast I
gain it back fast yeah and so this
journey for me started like 2016 that's
perfect and so I mean it's been up and
down but people always think like the
weight loss journey but you just have to
be always constantly dropping weight
it's like now you have to learn this is
a lifestyle yeah it took me a year to
lose 60 pounds so it was a long time so
like people they thought it was fast
because they haven't seen me in a minute
so I'm working on it but it was like a
year ish it took it took some time yeah
and I had to learn about healthy food
options why is it healthy why do I crave
and what I guess like the big thing too
I started feeling weak because I'm like
what is this food have so much control
over me yeah yeah like how weak in my as
a human being that if I don't eat this I
throw a tantrum you know what I mean
like I'm in a bad mood and what I found
out is I'm actually addicted to this
stuff yeah I am highly addicted to high
fat high carb foods and if I don't get
it I had the same symptoms as a [ __ ]
crackhead yeah I mean they said sugar is
just as addictive as cocaine
I heard it's more I heard it's worse and
so I'm talking custom [ __ ] like my
roommate came down once right this is
during the time I was like really trying
to like eat healthier food and this is
the doc I actually failed this time like
I was trying to get like healthy and eat
some healthier food and I'm talking I
was snapping him real quick like he came
down he goes hey man you want to go for
a walk I'll walk with your ugly ass back
upstairs dad he's like the [ __ ] top
of you storms upstairs
oh she that he was try be sentimental yo
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] away from me ugly hey
you I know but I was I was on some [ __ ]
I was I scratched myself in a corner
yeah we've been talking for an hour and
a half we've been doing it oh wow yeah
usually this golden goes about an hour
but now I can talk to you forever
forever yeah we haven't caught up in so
long I know but that's what this podcast
is about like I said like it's just I
feel like I have the most interesting
friends and every time somebody is like
yo you should bring this in that
celebrity I'm like yo so celebrities
aren't the only people with interesting
stories and perspective everybody has a
person most of this stuff is rehearsed
so they not gonna they're not gonna be
wrong I'm gonna bring a girl her name is
amen you know I'm saying listen I keep
it real yeah but what can they find you
you can find me on Instagram and Twitter
amen number two underscore that
amen to that amen to that and what about
the whole radio thing that you doing
yeah so it's every Sunday
third Sunday's are dedicated straight
strictly to me and my panel but it's
every third Sunday on 102.3 kjh which is
Stevie Wonder's radio station out here
in LA so if you're listening at 8:00
p.m. on Sundays you can chop it up call
it I live I love it you know so you
could catch genius brain on Spotify cast
box stitcher iTunes if you're on iTunes
make sure you give us a five star and
remember if you're watching the videos
always leave comments interact I want to
hear you speak even if you say something
stupid and I hate your guts not block
you I still want to see it first so so I
want to see all that beautiful stuff man
like keep it interactive share these
videos share the podcast and I want to
be with you on your everyday journey to
life because I'm telling you this is
gonna be the bed bed the bed podcast the
bed bugs going to be the back pocket
going to beat the bed pocket evil is
only signal amor only
SiC dollar more if you don't like it go
to hell okay but we'll see you guys next
we remember every Thursdays and Sundays
you will see a genius brain podcast
episode up I love you stupid sons of
[ __ ] you're beautiful out there
remember we talked about a lot of
self-love today [ __ ] love yourself
and if you don't I'm Rob you ass [ __ ]
peace